new Willy Wonka movie it looks like it's
going to be a pile of [__] it looks like
it's going to suck so hard it's so like
forced quirkiness and the last one the
Johnny Depp movie sucked so hard the
Gene Wilder Willy Wonka is the best
movie ever made I don't think it's like
the look that is uh Timothy chalamet's
problem here just like the whole vibe of
the movie sound looks bad why do you
want to see him when he's young I hate
that with the movie like hey you know
you love this character what about from
way before see how they got to the point
that you were interested in them I don't
care I'm gonna see Timothy Charlemagne
playing in heat as young Al Pacino